mr. issue guru I'm so pleased to meet
you and congratulations on the award of
course well thank you very much it's a
fantastic feeling I know that you just
got this award but I still have a small
gift for you I read that when you left
Nagasaki when you were five and moved to
England you left behind one of your
favorite toys I think I might have found
it could this be it that is absolutely
it and this fantastic it's for you that
is amazing
how did you find this that is truly
astonishing
well I searched the internet and I'm
amazed achieve and knew about this thing
yes so I remember this very well yes I
said you you you have to fire your gun
at this hen and if it's if you get the
target and then comes out at the bottom
and this is very special for me because
in the house in Nagasaki there were hens
that and so every morning would have
fresh eggs laid by our own hens and so I
think for that reason this is one this
is one of the toys I really missed yeah
well no you have it back and this was of
course a cunning way for me to nudge you
into talking about memory which is one
of the themes that runs through
practically everything that you write so
why is that well I think I have a I have
a deep relationship with memory because
of things like this
yeah at the start of my writing life I
was trying to preserve preserve memories
to some extent of my childhood but I
think in general now as a writer I I
prefer to write by saying instead of
saying you know this happened and then
this happened and then this happened I
prefer to say I think I can remember it
happened this way but perhaps I'm wrong
maybe it didn't happen quite that way it
was my brother present that day or maybe
he wasn't I like that way of telling a
story
I think it's richer and I think it comes
closer to to how we see our own pasts
and also how nations and countries see
their own part yes well I would say that
- right but because your main characters
constantly try to cope with
disappointment and they try desperately
to do this with dignity but then we all
try to categorize you right we try to
put you into different genres and themes
and does that annoy you
it doesn't really annoy me you know I
mean but in general I have to say I
think genres are not a particularly
helpful thing I think I think if you
honestly I think it's honest restrict
writers imaginations and most
importantly I think genres restrict
reading I don't I think people start to
read with prejudice around genres it
doesn't well you have said that you
would rather be a great musician any day
than an author but that can't be true
today right
I still love music and because I'm not
very good as a musician I think that's
the thing I would really love to do but
you know I think being at being a
novelist this has been a good second
choice but I can tell you that there are
millions of us that are really really
grateful that you became a writer
instead of a musician and thank you so
much for talking to me and please enjoy
the rest of the evening thank you so
much and thank you for this wonderful
from the pumpkin play with it - yeah
I'll do that